it's a
a pleasure as I remember
University of universi to have been
involved in this event and helping the
organization and I'd like to give the
the first word to ambassador for an
unload a melody by that
thank you very much professor Schwartz
I'm kind of dizzy I don't know about you
but that one and a half days of so much
informations oh it was the information
and to make any comment about it but but
first time you start by thanking us I
think every everyone said in each panel
and I think it's always good to say it
again how thankful we are I mean I am
certainly half of the consulate for so
many people put this together I am
looking at professor Jackson that I
talked to me a number of times about
this how much working people don't
understand I know that I have been told
they I'm looking at what the Claudia
Valley gia dinh Akiko no CoA who has
been organizing help me with the council
on this professor Schwartz of course
that I had a understand has been
involved since the very beginning since
the first molar version of this that we
had and of course and I'm glad and I'm
said I've just met and then we have
interesting conversation professors CMOS
Simone Celia and I think I have to think
also for the yeah for nostalgia to
DeVargas for also having being one of
the those who helped organize this or
promote this interesting as discussion I
what I really want to say is that I was
trying to take notes and it's probably
some of the view that followed all these
different subject matters and they what
it presses me is that the variety of
people with passion I think the word
passion has heard him a number type
people from academic word that really
want to do something about these
two countries I mean and people from
different universes are here present not
just from our host universe who else
would like to thank for the organizing
this the from I mean from different
perspectives I think those of us who
have followed this many subjects have
been dealt with here impressed with the
possibilities of cooperation I've heard
the number of words I think I heard word
cooperation collaboration exchange
connectivity comparison all kinds of
words to say that a lot can be done I
mean in the role of the universities the
role of the institution's like
furnishing to providers and others that
they can help to promote and foster and
help people to get together in a spread
knowledge and improve the quality of
life in Brazil
anyways why not because you've always
heard this the corporation's also helps
also those who are cooperating with the
other I've heard I'm looking here now
professors of a language I heard of the
language barrier how was important is
the language it's just and none of these
things could be possible without some
kind of a translation and some knowledge
of language and translation can be very
difficult it can be misleading and leave
lead to different I just wish the word
cooperation collaboration I heard
there's a difference you presume and
then even worse much of a difference but
there and then you dealing with specific
matters translations can be very
complicated an environment of course it
was easy to see the the interest of of
Brazil you have somebody described it
most of the Amazon or 60% 70% of the
Amazon diesel not only Brazil live in
Ecuador and remember
Ecuador always have defined the
countries Carter yet Ecuador is an
Amazonian country well I never had doubt
about it but they wanted to always
emphasize that so the importance of the
Amazon is for everybody it's not you
four four zero full consistent with
where the Lima zone is located but the
us at the real world so that any
cooperation with the Amazon I think it's
if item to anybody and we learn a number
of interesting facts about this into
small present
is just a small particle what could be
done was mentioned here in law which is
my field of expertise in the beginning I
I will discuss here the possible this is
that when there's need for something why
not to use the experience of another
country and and then Brazil are using
and the fight against corruption the
number of legal concepts have been not
transplanted I don't like that word but
borrowed some concepts have been used
and adapted to different situations in
reserve and it same goes for the other
various expertise history I was
fascinated here about the possibility
that digitalization is now permitting
people to exchange information much
faster from home so you can get
cooperation more and more at the
university levels from from that point
of view from even literature whatnot
literature is important I think there
are comparison of things that can be
useful and that that actually really
works in both ways and and then there's
of course something that happens here
because Brazil is a democratic country
and I think it's it's good that we have
this discussion lived in countries that
where democracy was not same and I and I
I'm glad to hear a number of the
challenges and problems in the social
problems especially when we go into
Brazil and the discussion education I
mean literacy or slums and when you talk
about organization and you talk about
health problems and the Zika virus and
all these things it's not that pursue is
unique and having promised I mean though
worst countries I remember when I was at
United Nations people would think of
Brazil I said well I think of the others
I mean comparison is always good even to
to make Brazilians feel better because
we're not that's who we don't want to be
you know there are people there not in
such the same situation and worst of all
they take not too much because they are
under some constraints political
constraints that cannot they don't have
freedom of press independence of
judiciary and and you know respect for
the rule we have to improve a lot on
this field but I am from the generation
when I started my diplomatic career
where we didn't have these things I mean
not completely not totally we've made a
lot of improvement so it's also good
that in a country like Brazil I think us
people from the academic world in us can
working and discuss ideas might not
agree my disgust is Sabo I don't like it
but it's possible and they're places
where this is not possible yet so I just
want to emphasize that possibility that
is something that hasn't been mentioned
but for me for my career so long 40
years of the private career that's
anyhow compulsory limit age I have to
retire soon so it's very agreeable for
me and I'm delighted to have one of my
last acts probably as a diplomat thing
is to to have had this opportunity of
having my country discuss this I run
here very small consulate just dedicated
to the Brazilian community you know the
problems that are presented live here in
the area and don't have resources for
promoting cultural exchanges or pro
trade and investment I do it by myself
with my help and my wife or is she
somewhere over there and some other day
prohet sit and somewhat of members of
the staff but it's more costly now to
have the finest universes in the u.s. in
the world I mean yeah promoting and
giving this opportunity for others to be
here and discuss some of the many
problems my countries funny faces it's I
mean it's so good to hear the Brazil map
it sometimes not good to be in a map in
a bad way it's good to be met but people
will need to cooperate
and this is the case I seek the resolver
see people interested in helping and in
cooperating with Brazil and I think this
is something to be thankful the
consulate in Brazil is and to be
supported I hope this is not just the
second because there was a smaller one
before and not the last I think is going
to continue the universe such as Yale
with such a fine University as many
others I guess heaven done much but now
thanks to the initiative
the professor's here we we see visit
back in a map I know you know courses of
English depends on the economy of Brazil
they're more yet more Brazil and curses
of Portuguese I mean they're more
courses that's at same thing is the
number of people who study Brazil does
Brazilian is probably there were
different motivations we have more
Brazilian misses in a pestle than now I
don't know but there is still neither
one thing that I in my no long
diplomatic career that I found is that
regardless of the government at the
moment in each country it is there are
some things that are permanent and
that's what the jobs of people like me
we have to do I mean to promote culture
to promote exchange the science the
technology some of the trade investment
some of the things it depends it
regardless of the country of course if
you help it depends maffei of course the
different governments but but they are
there that's the job of people of
goodwill in like I see here people with
passion people trying to promote the
goodwill people thank you so I was
thinking about what I should say after
this very interesting seminar and I
decided to tell you a story when I first
came to the u.s. to study 1982 I went to
Princeton
and with my wife I was recently married
and every time when I went to a coffee
shop small restaurant etc listening to
us beginning in Portuguese someone said
we speak Brazilian we speak Portuguese I
always had to face this question where
are you folks from and I said from
Brazil how nice
and how is it down there in the
beginning and since what Brazilians are
laughing is because they have faced the
same question probably and after after
the question I simply explained Brazil I
try to explain Brazil six months past
and I was really tired of trying to
explain Brazil to American waitresses
I wasn't succeeding so I have gotten
this very simple explanation it is
exactly like here only we lack we have
less roads and less phones at that time
you used to have public phones nowadays
we have a same number of phones public
from zero so we have less roads or less
a fault and of course less cars because
we are poor and this made them so happy
so happy and I could have my lunch so
professor cook asked me yesterday why
did I come here do you want the first
type of answer of a second one that's a
Jewish way of answering but why did I
come here and I also you put that
question to me yesterday I said to talk
to you and we have never met I didn't
know about your existence of course I
didn't have time to read the program
before I came because I do 100 things or
week different things and people
convinced me to come saying it was
important and I said I am going to come
because I want to see how our minds work
how do they see us
and of course I got more than that I got
how do they see us how Brazilians that
are here see you how Brazilians that are
here see Brazil and all of that and in
this very small room I have gotten a
microcosm of Brazil for example there
are things that we use words that we use
that have understatements but are
completely different than Americans for
example
and let me be slightly and polite mr.
ambassador said we are a democratic
country asking the Americas do you think
that's possible a democracy where the
question of public money is not
discussed no but in Brazil it is not
discussed a budgetary process is a third
class one it authorizes the executive
power to use up to that sum but doesn't
mean that he has to use that son it
doesn't mean that it has to fulfill that
public policy so it's a different notion
of democracy of course we have civil
liberties even more than here I think
I'm not bound to drink white wine
because it's fashionable to drink white
wine I can ask for a Coke Zero coke even
if it's bad for my health my doctor he
eats sweets and candies app over time
he's fat okay and he knows that he's
going to die of that because of that
live in 20 years or soil but it's part
of our freedom but have you noticed how
awful presidents even though once living
in here they demand for public action
the state God has to take action
the state God has to do this and that
this is part of how you function how we
are and we don't understand this we
don't understand that there are options
to be made because money is not
available so we'll have to make choices
the problem is how do you proceed the
choices this is the tricky question so
the road ahead for Brazil might be if I
have to put question mark for your
professors the thing is how do we
introduce the idea of choices democratic
choices scientifically based rational
choices whatever you want but what is
rational taken alone may become
irrational if you put several rational
things together there are several
examples in history that show that I'm
not speaking about public health and not
taking a particular example but what I
say is that our our framework nowadays
is of tremendous confusion puzzlement
and evolution in Brazil 1968 finally
finished it has finished here around 84
I believe in France around 87 or 88 in
German made by the same time but in
Brazil it's finished now because of a
military regime perhaps be it on the
right be aft on the left people survive
too long so in Brazil a big company is a
big steel mill not Google know Google
please so
if you go to some Paulo and many of you
I presume have ever had have had the
opportunity to fly to some bowl and you
fly over the city you must realize what
all those buildings there where built
cash no mortgages how many big cities
would you have in the states if you
didn't have mortgages hmm if we had
mortgages and we use the same ratio as
you do or financing we would have five
samples not one and why is that again
the budgetary process for choices with
mechanisms choices and how do you make
deals where people take compromises
between the short term and the long term
that's a thing
want to protect diversity you want to
protect minorities and so forth you have
to put this on a pipeline and you have
to make agreements and you have to make
that this thing become feasible without
feasibility it's impossible it's just
conversation between deaf people but I
are also blind and then don't have that
talks so this is only telepathy would so
and that's amazing resilience call
especially in economics unfortunately
there is no I believe not not many
economists here they do a mistake this
is your mistake we can't interact with
the US in any size what I remember was
in 1981 I was a student they read from
the Soviet era Vargas and there was a
semla with eight professors from the
u.s. MIT Harvard
etc all of them where or became nobel
prizes and one of them gave a brilliant
explanation on how we should correct our
monetary policy and then a former
minister of finances in Brazil said Tom
listen we don't have a term structure
the way you have the American professor
scientists fought for a while and said
then everything then ignore everything
that I have said that's it that's a
point so we are in the process of
finding solutions this is very
complicated
and Brazilian demand is for immediate
immediate immediate action because we
have a Bonapartist extradition
positivistic on the heart of all our
educated people and this is something
that we have to evolve so I came here to
find out how we could interact more and
learn more of course we cannot copy the
United States and certain fiscal aspects
because your public - don't tell anyone
are as bad as ours the only difference
is that you have an avian in each ocean
overworld okay we have to be more
conservative more German but anyway you
have an excellent budgetary process this
is part of democracy an excellent
budgetary process is an necessary
condition not a sufficient condition to
have a sequence of good budgets and I am
NOT going to get into technicalities but
we are in the process of
so pensions subsidies investment in
science when that's 1.2 percent of GDP
to anoint 1.2 1.3 Korea invests 4.2 how
are we going to compete when there's 70%
of what we invest we invest in science
basic science and then we follow sales
law know what says law says law said the
supply will create its own demand it's a
best way to go bankrupt ok
anyone that proposes me a sales law
initiative at fdv
I put him aside let him calm down
because I don't want to go bankrupt so
you have to niche to target them and
it's very important to target them and
know where demand is but this is very
obnoxious the world has to be the way we
think it is not the way it is how many
times haven't you faced this so this is
a big exercise of the exercise of
reality so this is my long answer but
the short answer would be just a simple
one I came to meet intelligent people I
came to meet intelligent people and to
learn and that I have learned and I
think all the panelists at the seminar
because I have learned a lot we have a
long way to go
we are not going to learn everything and
we should not copy everything as I
mentioned I think yesterday's somewhere
I don't remember even if it was here we
copied American federalism complete
disaster complete disaster we copied
German
social function of a contract complete
disaster
okay things that we may copy adapt look
after experiences so I think that this
was a wonderful seminar I think
University I think Oh ambassador I say
everywhere we are at the Morrissey at
the heart but we still have a long and
complicated way to go because that is a
tricky point no taxation without
representation that's what you see we
were born
not from your Mason's your Mason's drunk
on whom hours drive on the Jansenist
genetic dispute of 18th century which of
course you did lose the fourteenth
answer mate as my so we are still
discussing discussing the nature of a
state it's a very different thing it's
an evolution that we are discussing
[Applause]
well it falls to me to make the final
remarks here let me take this
opportunity to say that we are very
grateful for the presence of all of you
here I especially want to thank
ambassador by Heather and President Lee
out for your closing remarks I'm like to
thank the Council of Latin American
Studies here at Yale and especially
professor Claudia by the AG my colleague
and and director of the of the center
and also my colleague and friend
professor David Jackson for the
organization and helping in the in the
organization of this event I'd also like
to thank the Brazilian Ministry of
Education for co-hosting this conference
and we are particularly grateful also
for the support of the fundus algeria
broadness and also for a unit the help
of organization of unesco madhava know
that director and representative of
unesco in brazil and finally i'd like to
all thank all the participants both from
brazil and from the around the united
states for attending the conference and
for sharing their experience in their
research with us the conference has been
full of a wide discussion of rich topics
and we are grateful for to all of you
for attending the conference the next
step in the road forward will be as
David mentioned yesterday we are looking
to compile a book as a result of the
conference with participant and
moderators responses to the themes and
questions that were posed in the
conference and I would include the
remarks that we just had and enjoyed
from
people here at the at the table I'm
excited to see what will come from this
collaboration and as a personal note let
me say that this year the end of the
next semester I will be completing 51
years of university teaching my career
with Brazil actually begins a few years
before that when I went began as a
graduate student going to Brazil and I'm
particularly gratified by seeing this
conference and all of you here at this
university which has a long history of
contact with Brazil and a participation
on its faculty and amongst its students
of Brazilians and it's particularly
gratifying it's also my responsibility
at this the end of our meeting to to
pronounce those sinkhole atrocity
Shoreham Adele's Adele's Adele's eboydee
ashing oh no so semi-acoustic oligos
Brazil heirs
[Applause]
[Music]